foreign
[Music]
hmm
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the glitch
detraction oh
ah oh wait a minute what see I don't
like just walking in and seeing humans
here well that ain't right you've got
outlines I don't like that
man this is some bullying
huh
is that The Bite of 87
is this a precursor to The Bite of 87
guys I think it might be the bite of 87.
oh my God it's the moment before The
Bite of 87 the mythical the incredible
the horrifying bite of 87.
well and I'm getting a phone call it's
the reporters talking about The Bite of
87 shut up
I don't know my flashlight anymore so I
can't even read
or write people about the bite of 87.
well that was fun glad up wait a minute
a minute no I don't think that this is
The Bite of 87 guys I'm pretty sure this
ain't the bite of 87.
hmm
okay well this just seems like perfectly
ordinary nothingness nothing exceptional
about this
I have no concerns
[Music]
still nothing too concerning Oh no
just a little horseplay
foreign
[Music]
wait a minute
is that someone's frontal lobe in there
that uh
I don't know if that's what you would
call good I have expected the music to
cut out I thought that was the bite of
87.
guess not
oh
the music cut out
hi or didn't I do it for you
didn't I do it
did not
like when all I did was for you
it's a shotgun okay
I thought I was about to get the shotgun
of 87.
oh wow
foreign
whoops oh man I was that close to the
end well how was I supposed to know it
sure seemed like there was going to be
something more wait a minute that can't
have been it because I didn't get all
the things that I need to get
huh
interesting
nope
there's got to be something else let's
sit through the credits here this was
really well done by the way I did like
it I had some frustrations here and
there but when am I not an idiot idiot
pick up some frustrations who am I to
criticize what a wonderful piece of work
this was which it was
very nice
[Music]
oh I knew it
dude just left the new Fazbear
attraction my friend take all your stuff
and come here you have to see this oh
look he's someone sent to you just a new
location wait a minute
isn't that just the beginning of the
game
[Laughter]
oh no my frontal lobe well wait a minute
well hold on a second here well hold on
hold on wait a minute hold on
The Full Experience complete all
achievements okay find and play the tape
so there must be a tape somewhere in
there oh okay I gotta Boop all the
fredbears I gotta
um
okay so this might take some doing but I
gotta get all of these
and I don't know if I don't know if
there's gonna be someone else I mean
I'll get some more lore and hey I'll get
a few more jump scares maybe there's uh
for now maybe I'll never be able to get
that and I'll just look at the extras
because I always look at looking at the
extras and I always do appreciate the
work that these guys put into these
things because it's just
yeah biggest and most ambitious game I
have done to date I'm very grateful to
the entire Community for all the support
and amazing videos you guys make it is
something that I cannot describe thank
you so much developing this game has
been one of the craziest most ambitious
things I've ever done in the beginning
of this game was just another game but
it has turned into something that I
didn't even know we could reach get
incredible followers who show us their
love in every post we make I wouldn't
hesitate to do something like this again
which is really incredible because are
they just 8 18
my God
and that's all they have on patreon
look all this work goes into a game like
this this is up there with like some
studio games that I play you know this
is like the quality is just that good
they just put that much work into it oh
my God it makes me feel like a sham what
do we have here oh it's balloon boy okay
use the switches under the lights to
turn oh I can I can really get it moody
in here
oh yeah
let's get some nice backlighting on it
oh it's gooey
oh scary
hi good God all right
oh oh
hey guys how you doing
hello
ah
aha oh
nice
some of these are like really faithful
models I'm wondering if they actually
are the models in like Scott lent them
out because these are pretty damn
like I mean I don't have Perfect Memory
but they do seem a lot like the ones
that you would have seen
Yee
Scooby-Doo
it's coming to booby
hi Vani you know vanity still doesn't
make a whole lot of sense to me but
people seem to have taken a liking to
her and uh sure whatever
I don't know any of the story I bet
there's plenty of matpat video about all
this lore but I I don't think I've
watched a single lore breakdown video
about any of Five Nights at Freddy's
I don't think I have it all I haven't
read a single book I haven't done
anything about it
uh but who needs you when you're the
king when you wear the crown you know
weighs pretty heavy on your head I mean
you're kind of shrimpy I'm kind of
shrimpy you're not like the marionette
that's a pretty cool one that's a really
cool one that's well done well done for
this but I gotta imagine that there's
some kind of a secret
Endeavor to pry all the secrets out of
this unless it's a futile effort in
which you'll see me almost immediately
after this be like well that was a waste
of time
actually you know what to save myself
some trouble I'm just gonna go look to
see if there is a secret ending
[Music]
I'm so dumb
I'm so dumb cause the tape oh I'll just
show you but just to understand how dumb
I am everyone please make vague
references to how dumb I am in the
comments because I am extremely dumb and
now I gotta play this again I'm so dumb
you guys probably were all calling me
dumb in the last one but you know I I
don't keep up with what the news is
all right but let's hope I can get that
key again
oh crap
oh hey the key wait I saw it
it's right over there
I saw it glowing
wait a minute we might be in luck here
whoa whoa whoa
and wubble okay
and I can't close it but that's fine
because I'm in here now and the tape was
literally right here I am that dumb
but anyway you don't need intelligence
to be able to watch a VHS
get nice and close here
get a living body
woof
I don't like how you're treating these
scientific videos vanny find an arm vein
kind of hard to do with that suit
can't really see through those eyes
can't really palpate with those hands
inject 313a
move the body to have a clear view of
the back
you know make them supine roll him
supine
supine no not supine
opposite of super open the back open
back
open the back right up
I I feel like there's better tools
find and extract the RP component
role-playing component
[Music]
scream into the camera extract Remnant
from RP component
I feel like you didn't need to pull it
out of the body if you were going to use
your shirt
start Remnant condition tests end of
tape wait but what are the remnant
condition tests
oh but
but but but but
I'll need to watch that a few more times
before I'm able to understand what's
going on
well
I guess it's just repeat right
repeat oh
yeah yeah again all right I'm gonna go
die
because I ain't doing this anymore hey
loser hey oh my God
damn he was close oh there you have it I
actually don't believe that there's a
secret ending but I did see the secret
tape that all of you are yelling at me
to get and yeah well yeah well why did
you know what the ending was huh how do
you explain that how do you explain how
you knew where that was and you were
yelling at me because I didn't know how
did you know
economy with other YouTubers
were you watching other videos you mean
you didn't wait the two months that I
got to patiently get back so I can block
oh
[Music]
eyes you no you don't say anything
you've said enough
you've said enough just leave your likes
at the door along with your apologies
And subscribe and ring the bell and
whatever
like it means anything anymore just
empty promises
I can't believe this
thank you I guess for watching and as
always
maybe I'll see you
actually I'm not even gonna I'm not even
gonna do a sign off I'm not even gonna
I'm not even gonna say goodbye you just
go you go you you go you can leave
you're allowed to leave you may go the
video's over there's not gonna be any
more content it's done it's gonna be a
slow Fade to Black you can leave though
at any time because it's gonna take like
a minute it's gonna take a minute to get
done with this because I don't even care
anymore I don't even care anymore I
don't even care you can watch whoever
you want to watch it doesn't matter to
me it doesn't matter to me just good to
know that there are people that aren't
loyal that's fine this is a reality of
the world just crumbling around
everyone's picture of what the
perfection in the world is just just a
lie it's just a lie just a big fat lie
so you can go you can go at any time now
don't know why you're still here
boy you're really just hanging around
huh don't give me those puppy dog eyes
you're no chica or are you but you're
not that's the truth of it not that you
would know what that truth was
dishonesty runs through your veins right
next to the 318 RP gland which you don't
have
slurped out long ago
you probably know what that even means
you've been watching matpat huh you've
been watching mad Pat's videos yeah
that's what I thought oh yeah oh he
knows the Lord I have the crown